[Musique]
la chanson au cinéma dans la plomberie
c'était pareil
c'est du bon travail qu'il faut
présenter alors par exemple sur les
colonies de vacances était de la belle
ouvrage
oui moi je considère que à l'époque où
j'ai fait une vacance j'ai fait sa vie
[ __ ] enfin j'ai pas fait ça c'est ma
femme qui certainement a même incités à
chanter cette chanson parce que j'ai
chanté ça l'époque je faisais les boîtes
je disais bon mais ce soir je vais
essayer un truc enfants qu'on va se
marrer parce que c'est comme ça que je
ne voulais même pas faire lundi ça m'a
amusé j'ai pas fait ça pour l'argent du
tout puisque celui qui peut me dire
demain qu'il est capable de faire une
chanson pour gagner de l'argent
je voudrais bien qu'ils m'expliquent mon
il faut faire parce que moi je connais
pas de procéder ni des droits c'est de
revenir à ses colonies m'en voulez pas
que pour les colonies de vacances à ce
qu'elles ont été chantées par vous la
première fois ont suscité une vague de
critiques de protestation même interdite
oui mais c'est plus pareil déjà
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas je me permet
de chanter des choses aujourd'hui qui
finalement passe très bien sans très
bien acceptée alors qu'à l'époque on a
fait toute une malle vraiment fait une
pendule quand quand je lisais pipi dans
le lavabo
on m'a dit que c'était monstrueux que
j'avais pas drôle dire ça et on m'a
supplié notamment à la télévision à
l'époque de tous c'est lors d'une
émission en arrivant sur ce mot là j'ai
dit mais bon oui ou de jeux tous
supports rue mais d'abord et j'ai pas
envie de tout c'est parce que c'est ou
où je chante la chanson où je la chante
pas si on m'avait demandé de venir
chanter je vais la chanter mais
intégralement ans s'est rendu compte que
ce n'était pas un méchant gaillard on
vous a récupéré maintenance a peu
d'importance latin clown quoi peut-être
oui je sais peut-être pour beaucoup une
espèce de gugusses ça vous ennuie un
petit peu s'en faut
pas beaucoup lenteur je vous parlais
d'une phrase qui avait des milliers de
simon a pas tellement longtemps
il ya beaucoup de gens qui confondent
les mouret poil à gratter
c'est vrai et il pour une grande partie
du public je suis quand même dans le
poil à gratter
ça fait rien si c'est ça qui les amuse
et nommé 8 et oui peut-être mais ma foi
c'est comme ça c'est peut-être moi qui
suis encore un peu au stade du poil à
gratter
maintenant on peut pas plaire à tout le
monde et à son père c'est sûr rien
toujours qui détecteront cordialement
perret qui a toujours qui ce qui se
concluront dans dans le mauvais goût que
qu'on veuille bien m'attribuer mais
qu'est ce que vous pensez de tout ça ça
vous ennuie ça vous indiffère samadi
ferrat c'est parce que fait j'ai jamais
réussi à être convaincu par les
critiques
les lettres anonymes puis j'ai reçu chez
moi j'ai trouvé rarement quelque chose
de constructif dans les critiques
j'aurais et j'aurais vraiment aimé
trouver quelqu'un qui vienne me trouve à
la sortie d'un théâtre et qui me lisent
voilà moi j'aime pas ça pour sceller
telle raison je reçu au moins deux ou
trois ou cinq cents lettres d'insultés
peut-être elles sont jamais signé
moi je signe mes chansons
de droite à gauche de l'arrière gauche
derrière le fait que c'est oui mon chéri
je peux pas laisser les chansons que je
rêve de faire et les flics on part
toujours toutes les chansons de brassens
ou des tsé mais ça c'est rien c'est bon
en france et bonhomme c'est ce qui est
grave c'est les flics crs et des mecs
qui cogne
j'avais l'expérience personnelle de sa
wii que je ne peux pas raconter je
m'excuse beaucoup qui est vrai est
récente en plus vous acceptez un
chanteur un message à condition qu'on se
rende pas compte
un peu oui qu'est ce qui vous est digne
autour de vous et que vous dénoncez dans
vos chansons au au premier chef c'est la
connerie je trouve les cons plus
dangereux que les méchants lorsqu'on
interroge les gens qui qui ont un brevet
d'intelligence et qu'on leur demande
quelles sont vos chanteurs préférés
ils disent brassens brel ferré traîner
ferait traîner dis jamais tu es rey
n'ont jamais pourquoi ça parce que je ne
fais pas partie des classiques et je
ferai certainement jamais partie des
classiques et finalement je ne tiens pas
tellement à faire porter des classiques
c'est vrai ou c'est comme ça vous dit ça
comme ça non je dis ça sincèrement parce
que parce que je tiens pas faire partie
des choses officielles jamais toute
façon je ne crois pas c'est moi ça c'est
officiel oui absolument finir à faire de
moi avec un ami français sochaux c'était
je dis pas ça de façon péjorative du
tout ferrer a aussi oui encore plus
celui du non mais c'était moi je vous
dis il y aura toujours une ambiguïté
c'est il y aura toujours le gugusse qui
ressortira et finalement tant mieux
parce que c'est il faut être un peu
clown comme ça il faut démystifier un
peu les gens partitionnement ils sont
trop posé sur un piédestal ça devient
grave et ils croient en leurs
personnages moi je ne je souhaite jamais
trop croire au mieux
[Musique]